last year gdp grew by 2.2% the obr now
forecast it will grow by 2% this year
then two then 2.2% again in 2017 and
then 2.1 percent in each of the three
years after that over the next few
months this country is going to debate
the merits of leaving or remaining in
the European Union and I have many
colleagues who I respect greatly on both
sides of the argument the obr correctly
stay out of the political debate and
they do not assess the long-term costs
and benefits of EU membership but they
do say this and I quote them directly a
vote to leave in the forthcoming
referendum could usher in an extended
period of uncertainty regarding the
precise terms of the UK's future
relationship with the EU I am asking my
right old friends the chief secretary in
the paymaster general to undertake a
further drive for efficiency and value
for money the aim is to save a further
three and a half billion pounds in the
year 2019-20 at less than half a percent
of government spending in four years
time that is more than achievable while
maintaining the protections we have set
out public sector organisations will
have a new duty to ensure that those
working for them pay the correct tax
rather than giving a tax advantage to
those who choose to contract their work
through personal service companies loans
to participate errs will be taxed at 30
2.5% to prevent tax avoidance and will
tighten rules around the use of
termination payments termination
payments over 30,000 pounds are already
subject to income tax from 2018 they
will also attract employer national
insurance so from April next year we
will restrict interest deductibility for
the largest companies at thirty percent
of UK earnings while making sure firms
whose activities justify higher
borrowing are protected with a group
ratio rule next we're setting new hybrid
mismatch rules to stop the complex
structures that allow some
multinationals to avoid paying any
tax anywhere or to deduct the same
expenses in more than one country then
we're going to strengthen our
withholding tax on the royalty payments
that are our some firms to shift money
to tax havens and lastly we're going to
modernize the way we treat losses we're
going to allow firms to use losses more
flexibly in a way that will help over
70,000 mostly British companies but with
these new flexibilities in place we'll
do what other countries do and restrict
the maximum amount of profits that can
be offset using past losses to fifty
percent corporation tax was twenty-eight
percent at the start of the last
Parliament and we reduced its twenty
percent of the start of this one last
summer I set out a plan to cut it to
eighteen percent in the coming years
today I'm going further by april twenty
twenty will fall to seventeen percent
the new pressure the small business rate
relief will raise from 6,000 pounds to a
Maxima threshold of 15,000 pounds and
i'm also going to raise the threshold
for the higher rate from 18,000 pounds
to 50 1000 pounds let me explain to the
house what this means from April next
year 600,000 small businesses will pay
no business rates I am today cutting in
half the supplementary charge on oil and
gas from twenty percent to ten percent
and I'm effectively abolishing petroleum
revenue tax to dragging this key
Scottish industry and supporting jobs
we've agreed a single powerful East
angular combined authority headed up by
an elected mayor and almost a billion
pounds of new investment we've also
agreed a new West of England marilith
ority and they too will see almost a
billion pounds invested locally and the
authorities of Greater Lincolnshire will
have new powers new funding and a new
mayor north south east and west the
devolution revolution is taking hold and
because
we're not prepared to let people be left
behind I'm also announcing a major new
package of support worth over 115
million pounds to support those who are
homeless and to reduce rough sleeping so
we're giving the green light to high
speed three between Manchester and Leeds
we're finding new money to create a
four-lane m62 and will develop the case
for a new tunnel road from manchester to
sheffield my honourable friends for
carlisle Penrith and Hexham have told us
not to neglect the north pennines so
we'll upgrade the a66 and the age 69 to
i said we would build the northern
powerhouse we put in place the mares
we're building the roads we're laying
the track we're making the northern
bowser reality and rebalancing our
country the government that is
delivering Crossrail one will now
Commission Crossrail to I know this
commitment Crossrail two will be warmly
welcomed by the leader of the Opposition
the right honourable member for
Islington it could have been designed
just for him because it's good for all
those who live in North London and are
heading south first I can announce that
we're going to complete the task of
setting schools free from local
education bureaucracy and we're going to
do it in this Parliament
I am today providing extra funding so
the by 2020 every primary and secondary
school in England will be will be in the
process of becoming an academy second
we're going to focus on the performance
of schools in the north where results
have not been as strong as we'd like
London's school system has been turned
around we can do the same in the
northern bars of today I can announce
that we will introduce a new sugar levy
on the soft drinks industry and let me
explain how it will work it will be
levied on the company's it will be
introduced in two years time to give
companies plenty of space to change
their product mix it will be assessed on
the volume of the sugar sweetened drinks
they produce or import there will be two
bands 14 total sugar content above 5
grams per 100 milliliters a second
higher bands for the most sugary drinks
with more than 8 grams 400 milliliters I
know that fuel costs still make up a
significant part of household budgets
and weigh heavily on small firms
families paid the cost when oil prices
rocketed they shouldn't be penalized
when oil prices fall we are the party
for working people so i can announce
that fuel duty will be frozen for the
sick year in array
tobacco duty will continue to rise as
set out in previous budgets by 2 percent
above inflation from 6pm tonight while
hand rolling tobacco rise by an
additional three percent and to continue
our drive to improve public health we
were a formal tobacco regime to
introduce an effective floor on the
price of cigarettes and consult on
increased sanctions for fraud the
headline rate of capital gains tax
currently stands at twenty-eight percent
today I'm cutting it to twenty percent
and I'm counting her capital gains tax
paid by basic rate taxpayers from
eighteen percent to just ten percent
from April 2017 anyone under the age of
40 will be able to open a lifetime aye
sir and save up to 4,000 pounds each
year and for every four pounds you say
if the government will give you one
pound so put in four thousand pounds and
the government will give you 1,000
pounds every year until you're 50 you
don't have to choose between saving for
your first home or saving for your
retirement with the new lifetime aissa
the government is giving you money to do
both from April next year I am raising
the tax free person house to eleven
thousand five hundred pounds I'd say tax
car for 31 million people it means a
typical basic rate tax payer will be
paying over a thousand pounds less
income tax than when we came into
government five years ago and it means
another 1.3 million of the lowest pay
taken out of tax altogether
sure justice delivered by conservative
meal from April next year I am raising
the tax free person house to eleven
thousand five hundred pounds that's a
tax car for 31 million people it means a
typical basic rate tax payer will be
paying over a thousand pounds less
income tax than when we came into
government five years ago and it means
another 1.3 million of the lowest pay
taken out of tax altogether essential
justice delivered by conservative meal
mr. Dabney speaker remain another
commitment that our manifesto and that
was to increase the threshold to which
people pay the higher rate of tax that
threshold stands at 42,000 385 pounds
today I can tell the house there from
April next year I'm going to increase
the high rate threshold to 45,000 pounds
this is a budget that gets the investors
investing savers saving businesses doing
business so that we build for working
people a low-tax Enterprise Britain
secure at home strong in the world I
commend your house a budget that puts
the next generation first
you